من جانبها قالت القياده الوسطى الامريكيه
ان جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين شنت مساء
الثلاثاء هجوما معقدا من اليمن بالمسيرات
والصواريخ المضاده للسفن واضافت القياده
ان الهجوم تم بمسيرات ايرانيه وصواريخ
كروز وصواريخ مضاده للسفن ولم يسفر عن
اصابات او اضرار وقالت ان الحوثيين شنوا
هجومهم على خطوط الشحن البحريه الدوليه
الجنوبيه البحر الاحمر واوضحت ان طائرات
وسفنا امريكيه وسفينه بريطانيه اسقطت 18
مسيره وصاروخي كروز
وصاروخ بالستيا مضادا
للسفن وقال وزير الدفاع البريطاني جراند
شابس ان السفينه البريطانيه دياموند نجحت
مع السفن الحربيه الامريكيه في صد اكبر
هجوم من الحوثييين حتى الان في البحر
الاحمر واضاف شابس في بيان ان المملكه
المتحده وحلفائها اوضحوا ان هذه الهجمات
غير القانونيه غير مقبوله على الاطلاق
واذا استمرت فان الحوثيين
سيتحملون
العواقب